okay we're ready to go
yes bob we're now live right uh
may i welcome you all to this biddeford
harbour board
um i would remind you that it is
a public meeting where the public
will and can in the future watch it so
be careful what you
say um
you will please stay muted unless you're
speaking
and if you wish to speak put your hand
up and the operator will pick it up and
we should be aware that you wish to
speak
first of all we'll deal with apologies
for absence
yes chair one apology mr hyde aka
thank you that's an independent member
uh we move on item two the minutes of
the last meeting held on the 30th of
january
pages three to six
i will move through them taking the
marking
at the bottom of the page page three
page four page
five page
six so you're all happy with that
uh we have to take a recorded vote that
we accept those
minutes so we'll do that right away
bob will need a proposal in second day
oh sorry
uh i'll propose it from the chair if
someone would second it
oh james thank you
can i ask a question please yes
certainly
um on item 32
um it's mentioned that there was going
to be discussion with evans transport
and i wondered if that had actually
happened
regarding both transport and storage
chair i can report i did have a brief uh
conversation
with uh nigel evans um we didn't
actually resolve
anything but we i think it would
definitely be worth perhaps even
yourself as the chair of the harbour
board
um and maybe richard myself
and uh and nigel evans catching up
because he does have some interesting
thoughts about the future of the harbor
and how it looks from their perspective
as stephen and things like so
i think that's something we should pick
up in a more formal manner
i'm quite happy to do that okay we'll
set something up on that chair
if you would thank you mr buddy
um moved and seconded recorded vote
please
thank you chair councillor hicks for
hansen mcgoff
abstain councillor christie
chancellor james paul pence of rossi
oh and mr gibbs or
that's five for extension chair
my apologies right we move on to
item three the action list
who's dealing with that one
yeah i can do that
[Music]
so on the action list thank you chairman
the action list item number three no
health checks have been carried out on
vessels to date
although we have received covered
information from environmental
health officers any further
information coming forward on that we
will keep the board updated
uh looking at the action listed so has
the fee been paid
there's been no checks carried out
chairman so no fees are being paid now
a lot to my knowledge that better stay
on the list then
the other two items the biddeford harvey
user group
um we haven't had any feedback from the
port user group
but we have had discussion amongst
ourselves as to whether
um as to whether we as the harbor
authority forms its own port user group
but
the last time we spoke with your good
self-chairman you were not minded to
create that port user group so
my interpretation of that is this board
acts in many ways as a consultative
forum
is that this question lies with you sir
okay uh item 17
on the list sean that's yours
no action yeah well yes joe we um we've
introduced some
so sorry so let's take you back to
january when we talked about this there
was some concern about some
people ignoring the speed limits in the
harbor um
that's been exacerbated somewhat by the
fact that there have been more
users of the estuary this year than than
in previous years so i think the
response to
in to covid and the fact that people
can't go abroad and people have been
holidaying in this area
we've found many more users
coming down from the um the
the authorized zone of the river um
sort of further on up to uh past the new
bridge
into the harbour area and i certainly
witnessed this year
many speed boats coming down through so
we
introduced some extra speed limit
signage up at the apple door end
and i definitely think we need to
introduce some more
uh signage around the estuary user's
code of conduct
at their access points to the estuary so
that would be the
slip way at bank end probably somewhere
on the key
and the apple door but having said that
we haven't put any of those signs in
place
because uh there is an item coming to
community and resources i believe after
a notice of motion from councillor ford
to discuss um speed boats and
um jet skis on the estuary
and it's likely that this is this will
get referred back to you
uh as harbour boards to discuss how you
want this managed within the harbour
one of the things that's been discussed
was that they
one of the ideas to be discussed should
i say is that
that we stop launching apple door
and promote launching in biddeford now
that would obviously take a change of
management arrangements for you as
harbour board
because currently you wouldn't commit
people using jet skis within your harbor
so so i'm not sure that we can do too
much
i think perhaps paul who attends the
tortora jestery forum
could take the item back to them and see
whether they they would agree
and perhaps as as a forum there are
other partners on there who could
contribute
towards the cost of introducing some of
the
code of conduct signage but in terms of
speed limits and things
you might want to review those more
formally after discussions of cnr
okay any other comments counselor
chrisley
yes could i just take up that point
because uh
the idea that we'd move all the jet skis
down from mcelroy down to
biddeford uh councilman mcgoff and i
represent
that area there's a huge housing estate
next to it
and basically over my dead body and as a
harbour board we control that area
can we actually forbid the launching of
jet skis from the bank end slip way
can we actually do that as a harbour
board
would you like me to comment on that
chairman yes please
um we don't currently have the power to
do that councillor christie
and the next uh the next report that
we're bringing to you
um the the moorings and facilities
policy where we're also looking for a
direction from your good selves
to start looking at general directions
and or bylaws for the port
that would be the sort of thing we would
look to control
if you want to control access onto the
waters
at slipways a large electronic barrier
or a manned uh gate facility would
probably be the most practical way
forward
chancellor christie yeah just come back
on that because
um one of the issues that was raised by
council of ford when this first came up
was that
uh we were supposed to be charging
people using the epidural
subway for launching their jet skis
[Music]
and from what i can see launching them
from bank end is free
it seems a bit odd that if torridge has
two slipways one's free and one's
chargeable if we start getting stricter
we're going to have to do something
about the bank end slipway
sooner or later because everyone will
come down there
and as i mentioned there is a big
housing estate
right next to it not to mention uh
riverbank house of course although i'm
sure the officers can work through any
noise
sean so thank you chair um
so just so that you're fully in the
picture about how we manage things down
at church fields in epidural although
it's outside of the hybrid so
there is no longer a a launch permit
there used to be a permit
launch down there there was a slipway
warden who would give issue people with
a priority
for a payment of a fee uh that service
stopped five years ago
um and so the simple uh
the only charge associated with
launching from
church fields is if you park your
trailer that you've launched your jet
ski or your boat from in the car park
you're expected to put a
pain display ticket on that on that
trailer
so uh so so there isn't a sort of
disparity between biddeford
and uh and appledore in that respect
um one thing that i would say is that
the code of conduct specified the the
sort of
powered vessels user area to be where it
is for a reason and that that was
because
it was the safest place because it's out
the way of many other users
including the rowing clubs and people
like that but also because of the
impacts on wildlife
and and so i think it before
um we sort of make some fairly serious
decisions about
where we permit use of things or where
we
stop launching or encourage launching we
need to do some consultations
a bit wider because it's not as
straightforward as we don't like
somebody using this particular space
anyone else wishing to speak on that
yeah i think mr puddy would like to
speak right
yes um all i wanted to say was that um
the the signs on the new bridge
highlight the
speed limits in the harbor area however
i've witnessed
jet skis and speed bulbs actually
operating above the old bridge
so i think it needs to be made clear
that once they pass the new bridge
that's
within the um the speed limit area
because even
more damage is potentially being done to
wildlife once you pass the old bridge
for a comment
anyone else wishing to speak
so we move on to minute number eight
estuary
sampling dredging anything to be said on
that
um yes chairman um the uh
that project was something that we uh
did a couple of years ago with our
partners boss garliss and we've got
we've got a license to take samples
with a view to whether the sam could be
dredged from the river
for commercial purposes um buscar
lost interest in that project due to the
costs associated
with the sampling process recently
other stakeholders the yellend
facility have shown an interest in
extracting sand for commercial purposes
so the project has come back on screen
i've not done anything about it
to date uh due to covid
but we've had a discussion with your
good self and we are we have we're
talking about going down to pad stone
meeting with the harbor authority there
and seeing how how they manage their
sand extraction on the river camel
thank you thank you
i confirm that we have indeed had
discussions
anyone wishing to speak
nope right that's the action list dealt
with
we now move on to item 4
which is
the register of public speakers
i have one person who
has made a register to issue a statement
which will be read out by someone at the
meeting i hope it's not going to be me
because i can't find it on the screen
very easily
sure is that from mr renton yes
i'll read that out chair right excuse me
so this is from mr bob renton
we go as guardian of the envy john adams
number 244
on the historic ship register the oldest
veto in the harbour
that has been anchored there since 1986.
my rights have been challenged many
times by tdc to clear the poor shore at
east water for redevelopment
i have repeatedly proven those rights
with four previous solicitors
who have sought legal counsel on the
matter
at this meeting you'll be asked to
consider applying to the ministry of
transport for power of giving general
directions
there's an expensive legal process and
can take more than three years
these powers have not been needed in the
past and no compelling evidence is
offered in favor of them
nor any financial benefit to be derived
except by ashford's
solicitors the proposed mooring policy
exceeds the powers of tdc both the power
to levy rates and the power to make
bylaws are limited to the rating limits
as defined in the 1925 benefit arbor act
rating limits means the key and wharf
and sand or soil
held as a pertinent thereto by the
corporation as proprietors of the key
and wharf that the harbour master should
be seeking more power and ash
more money is not surprising it's what
it is what is in the best interest of
the harbour that is important here
lacking any local knowledge or
sensibility the harbour master has
trodden on many toes since he took up
position
behaving in an officious and overbearing
manner to those that displease him
this is behavior that will not be
tolerated within tdc
and i don't think it should be chopped
by the sword
certainly be not beyond the rating
limits
the harbour resources are here being
directed to legal services that should
rightly be spent on improvements of the
harbor
and this is wasteful the proposed new
powers to the harbour master if exercise
would amount to
ethnic cleansing and would have human
rights implications as well as
harbor law to consider they speak to the
character of the person
proposing these extra powers thank you
for listening
well we've heard it we'll consider it
later on i would suggest
right item 5
agreement of the agenda between parts
one and two there are no part two items
so
everything will be done in public today
item six urgent matters brought forward
by my consent
i personally have none does anyone else
have any
chair just one one thing to for for
members to note i think really
is that we've had a change of management
arrangements in the harbor and
so people might be familiar with me
having more of an active role in this
that role on an interim basis is being
filled by richard
as i've stepped into a slightly
different position on an interim basis
as well
so so richard haste is your go-to
manager for the harbour
as it currently stands thank you it's a
promotion from richard it's much
cleaner and tidier than his normal work
i got a question bob
yes um just a quick one for the
harbormaster pool
the um boat that came in there's a yacht
that came in um
instead of taking on water i believe and
do you have an update on
whether they were actually taking on
water or
anything at all to say about that
uh yes councillor rossi um i've had
a number of meetings with the owner of
the vessel
and also a meeting this morning with the
boat builder who um has been employed to
do works on the vessel
i have agreed uh that the vessel can
stay
in the port for a number of months to
affect repairs
so that she is seaworthy and able to go
to sea
and i'm also in the process of cutting
out an
investigation around
an incident where the vessel went to
ground in our pilot's approaches
and that's been carried out by our
senior pilot but i'm comfortable
that the vessel's in a safe berth
and uh is being attended to by a an
experienced boat builder
and over the winter she will be repaired
and and make ready for sea in the spring
excellent thank you
any other councillors or anyone wishing
to speak
yeah right we move on to item
seven the accounts
chair i'll go through that with the
committee that's okay
so you have it before you're on page
eight
i just mentioned it number seven
so it's split into two parts which is uh
the harbor and the pilotage uh
and a total down at the bottom um
and for the harbor itself which is on
the shore
is we are um under budget well we're
over budget at the moment or project
profile budget
and this is because we've only had one
clay ship in this quarter so we're
actually
six thousand a pound down on profile
budget projected
um the costs are there in front of you
which is
a slightly different format than you
normally receive it
but it's all quite self-explanatory but
on the upside of that
is that the uh pilotage
has increased um
and it's better than it is this quarter
so we're actually
three thousand pounds up on what was the
profile budget but points to note
is that going on quarter one because we
have budgeted for five
ships into the harbour this year
but we're now only looking at three
potentially um
is the net forecast for being over
budget
is going to be eight thousand but that
is as of quarter one and as you know
and the committee knows that that could
change
any questions
questions from anyone councillor
christie
yeah can just ask one thing about the um
the wages the crane drivers
wages um did we follow
him during the lockdown because
we're in a strange did we actually do it
uh
as we go along that he works minimal
hours
anyway and was um on call um as the port
was open
yeah because he is a slightly older
gentleman
he has he he's been available throughout
cobid
uh he was in the port uh last night uh
he was here on monday and as richard
said he's been coming in on an ad hoc
basis
so he has been available and when he
comes in
he fills out a time sheet so he's
he does do very minimal hours and
obviously a lot less during kobe
thank you thank you
anyone else wishing to speak
well it's still unhappy oh
someone with their hand up i believe
councilman goff chair
thank you mcgoff right thank you ask mr
chairman i wouldn't button
to tell me to speak um i just want to
recognize the christie there about the
crane uh the crane driver um i'm not
sure if he said was he furloughed or not
i don't think
the question was actually answered but i
do want to note it probably noted
he's probably the greatest asset we've
got on our river that michael he's
absolutely fantastic i don't think he
gets enough
uh recognition that you should do i've
come to you mr hayes
several times a few incidents he's been
involved in i think he's done absolutely
fantastic and i would like it probably
noted to him whether it's a letter
coming from the board just to
express our well i'm very happy what he
does for the harbor i think he's
i an older gentleman he's got
old-fashioned values and it's brought
benefit needs
thank you
i'd second that well
glowing reports for staff unusual and
very pleasant to hear
can we all agree on that
should we take a formal motion on it
please yes
we've got it proposed and seconded
counseling gotham counselor christy
will make a formal vote hopefully to
make it unanimous
thank you chair councillor hicks
for councillor mcgough
four answer christie oh
ansley james or
councillor ross c more and mr gibbs
or unanimous chair
thank you i'll leave that to be done by
the officers
but i will sign it if necessary
uh we now move on to item
eight i think eight or nine whoops
item eight safety management system
harbor master
thank you chairman uh this is a standing
item
um on the safety management system and
the compliance of the port with the
portland safety code
it's covered in the it's it's it's
covered in a great deal of debt
in the next two reports
indeed right nothing more to be said in
my opinion on that one
item nine
the port and harbor activity report
again a verbal report
thank you chairman um i've changed the
report
process to this for most of the
activities of the port have been covered
through the various um
various reports have been in front of
members today that's including the
security report
uh the portman safety code compliance
and and the um
and the moorings and facilities policy
so pretty much that's pretty much
been covered been very quiet these last
three months and
the entire country has been in lockdown
so there's not
not a great deal to report on on
activity so
on the commercial activity i think
that's right but a lot of people have
been using
the estuary particularly haven't they
[Music]
um yes sir
lockdown when we came out of lockdown
back in may
there was a real surge uh to use the
river
um and we discussed that earlier with
with churchfield's
slipway um we're seeing a lot of people
launching kayaks um the rowing club are
back on the water
and the rivers come back to life after
lockdown
we have had a new officer join the tdc
and uh their role will be to encourage
um
water sports for biddeford going forward
so
i'm hoping in the next uh the next um
meeting i'll be able to report further
on the progress that that offer is made
in encouraging people to get out onto
the river tour in the river college
thank you thank you anyone else wishing
to speak on that item
nope okay we can move on now to what i
would call main business
item 10 port marine safety code
compliance
mr hey sir
thank you chairman i'll lead on this
report
the purpose of the report is to report
to members of the biddeford harbour
board
on the role of the harbor authorities
the duty holder their duties powers and
responsibilities described within the
portland safety code
and the guide to good practice on port
marine operations
uh i would ask the board to note this
report and decide
how the role of the duty holder will be
fulfilled in the future
um members and officers aware
we had a portman safety code training
day back in february
before kovis myself and a number of
members attended that
uh including uh your good self-chairman
and uh i felt that was a very
useful um exercise
and in in many ways it's kick-started
this uh report
um members and uh were also offered the
opportunity to do portland safety code
in the last couple of weeks uh training
for me and safety code training
i'll um so no so quite a few of us done
the training lately so
we had a bit of an insight into this
report i'll talk you through the
salient points of the report in order
us as a harbor authority to comply with
the portman safety code
as a statutory hub authority we must
consider
the 10 measures that are outlined in
this report
it's my personal opinion that we're
complying
with everything all of those apart from
one the duty holder where we need
today to formally identify and designate
the duty holder
and whose members are individually
collectively accountable for compliance
with the code
and their performance and then
item number 10 is the legislation
about reviewing our existing powers and
seeking additional powers that is
covered
in the next report um so that's the
report in front of you
um
uh nothing really on financial
implications human resources etc
officers are recommending that this
report is noted
discussed and we recommend that the
community and reese's team
the formal duty holder for biddeford
harbor authority
so obviously from this board if you
recommend that that will go up to cnr
for ratification thank you thank you
questions could you read the
recommendation again
because my internet certainly hiccuped
in the middle of it
yes sir we are recommending that this
report
noted and discussed by members and the
recommendation
made to the parent committee community
and resources
is that the duty holder for the port of
biddeford
will be the community and resources
committee
so we're recommending seeing our
committee to be the duty holder
for the purposes of the portland safety
code compliance
thank you paul now i confirm i did
attend that meeting and
it it was a meeting which covered all
harbors from the smallest to the
greatest
and it became very clear that we had a
gap in this point so i'm glad that the
effort has been put in to
try and solve what is inherently a
problem
who carries the cam and
i brooded it at the time and i believe
the officers have come up with the right
proposal but i throw it open to the
meeting
sure mr gibbs would like to speak please
yeah i actually prepared a written piece
here on the basis i might not
be able to attend in person today so
probably
appropriate if i read it out because
it's i tried to set out my thoughts
probably more clearly than i could if i
was speaking
without any notes the duty holder is
accountable to the mca
for the port's compliance with the port
marine safety code
and as such is a fundamental pillar of
the code
it seems to have been an assumption that
the duty holder
is the harbour board but this cannot be
the case as the duty holder
has to be accountable people can people
and organizations cannot be accountable
things they do not control
the harbour board does not control it
nobody can recommend to the council
this situation where it seems the port
does not have an acceptable
nominated duty holder is a serious
omission
and puts the port in default and if the
mca were to become aware
they would come down longer like a ton
of bricks
the council should be in no doubt about
the seriousness of this situation
and to focus mines they should remember
that the port's duty holder
needs to be submitting the required
three yearly
comp compliance report to the mca by the
by march
next year in the current circumstances
the arrangements should be put in place
as a matter of some urgency
to bring any newly appointed duty holder
up to speed so there'll be no delay in
submitting the compliance report
thank you it seems to me logical and
i'll propose that the
harbour board accepts this
recommendation
and asks the community and resources
committee to
consider and accept responsibility
is there a seconder to that
mr gibbs yes i second that
any other comments
yeah i have one bob yes but
would it have to be cnr could it be full
council
cnr is the management committee of the
council
and i think that they can make a
decision on this
um they can make decisions regarding the
harbor
so that's where the buck stops to some
extent
okay no doubt stays he'll tell me if i'm
wrong
actually hicks i'm not gonna tell you
that you're wrong
right well there you are gentlemen can i
i've got to propose
i've made a proposal and i've got a
second there
that needs a recorded vote i believe
yes chair thank you chancellor hicks
for councillor mcgough
boar councillor christie oh
hencely james or pencil rossi
or and mr gibbs oh
unanimous chair thank you
we now move on to the next
item which
is on page
[Music]
14 and it's item 11.
i don't know who's taking this one
whether it's richard or paul
okay i am again chairman uh
item 11 the moorings and facilities
policy and general directions um
the morrison facilities policy is
attached to this report
uh the purpose being to present members
of the biddeford harbour board
the operational moorings and facilities
policy for consideration
and approval and further a strategic
position on implementing general
directions for the safe and efficient
management of the harbour
in compliance with the portland safety
code um
this report uh the morrison facility
policy has been before
you uh at a previous meeting and so it's
been out to consultation
already uh once my
understanding of the situation of this
board is again
it's acting as consultative body for
stakeholders
to have input into the moorings and
facilities policy
and if you recommend that this goes up
to community and resources
committee in the very near future there
will be
another opportunity uh for this morrison
facilities policy to go out to
consultation
and for stakeholders to have another say
in
how the in how um policy
goes forward i think we've had some
input
[Music]
so really that's that's all i've got to
add to that the report is in front of
you and i will
um
legal implications um for this report
is in order to seek designated
designated status
and the consultation process having had
discussions
with stacy and sean and richard we've
come to the conclusion this is something
that needs
specialist marine uh support
and we'd be looking to use external
marine lawyers
there is a financial implication to it
and i think that's something
when we've done more work on this we can
bring back to the board
officers are recommending we discuss
the policy and take a decision
to implement the moorings and facilities
policy
and from here it would proceed to the
communities and resources committee
for ratification that would then
give more time for further consultation
to take place
with stakeholders further to this we are
recommending that the hard board
gives strategic instruction to the waste
and recycling manager
richard haste and myself and the harbour
master
to proceed with the process of gaining
designated status
for the board and commencing
consultation on a new set of general
directions to the port
none of this can be achieved without
formal consultation
which then we would then have to
demonstrate to the department for
transport that we have
formally consulted before they would
give us that status
i'm happy to take any questions on that
chairman
right thank you paul richard do you want
to add anything
no no not this moment i think paul's
covered it very very well
obviously it's something if we want to
progress the harbour uh
and give paul the the powers to to
actually
take care of the issues that are
happening this is the way forward i
believe
well the whole principle of the
management of the harbor has been a
mystery to me for
many years and to get something
properly written down on paper with some
statutory basis will be a great help if
we can do it
so i'm going open to the meeting now the
first one wishing to speak is councillor
mcgoff
thank you mr chairman um at the moment i
would like to see this deferred
because of the financial implications we
these financial medications are going to
be huge
and we've got no detailed financial
details here to actually present to
anybody
let alone community resources as i know
with this council at the moment
figures have got to be spot on before we
take it any further
um for us to comply fully with the
harbour and the facilities
and obviously he's got to run 24 7. um
so you know have we got somebody
available 24 7.
and do we have running water and run it
and electricity
actually on the harbour to make it a
full commercial pool
because as i see at the moment we don't
so we're not providing
what we're actually getting rents for
could somebody answer that question
from police and chad i'm happy just to
sit back and another question moment
please
financial legal implications i would
suggest
we have to set the ball rolling and
those are things which will come to
light
during the process of going to cnr in
public consultation
you can get a quote we could have had a
quote three years ago it would be out of
date now
so we know it's going to be expensive
but
there we are as for the second part well
i look to the officers
um thank you chair i mean we we do have
a
a a very good idea of what costs would
be
um but we we're looking to bring that
back
to the to the next board meeting with a
more comprehensive um breakdown of costs
and how the whole process would work
water and electric we provide we can
provide water and electric
throughout um throughout throughout the
harbor estate
council might be referring to
the relationship we have with certain
vessels and providing facilities to them
but
the the entire estate is able to provide
water and electric
as required by um by our stakeholders
councillor christie thank you um
yes i've i looked through this and on
page 29
there's a bit about um fuel and
and members of the public are drawn to
my attention
the house boats some of which have got
their gas bottles just on our riverbank
without any sort of
cover over them at all and it does talk
there on page 29 at the top about
authorized storage tanks and containers
i don't know if they've been authorized
because
the members of the public were fairly
worried that you know
something could go wrong with these i i
don't know if this this
new set of rules will cover that
uh counsellor there could be an issue
there
um i'll defer this to to stacy
the vessels in question uh come under a
court order and
um that's something that's um we've been
dealt through our legal services
want me to come in chair yes please hi
yeah there's there's a couple of issues
here so the one
the first one um just going back to the
the point raised by councillor mcguff is
in relation to the
the mooring policy and this is the
policy that's been drafted
and recommended there's no cost account
attached to that council mcgoff
and that's a policy that we want to put
in place to allow
um the harbour pastor to be able to
regulate the harbors as as we are
um so one of the recommendations is that
harbour board today recommend this
policy go forward for approval
uh to cnr or not as the case may be but
there's there's no
cost um the cost i think that that
paul was discussing was it related
to the general directions now as i
understand it paul
has drafted those general directions by
a large
um and the uh
with them proposed to go out to
consultation and have
a lawyer look at those and paul's quite
right i don't have that capacity or that
expertise within my legal team it's a
real specialized subject
but actually it's with um implementing
them and going to their department of
transport
and that would be the cost and we could
get a quote in relation to that if
if that assists i'm talking to council
just going back to council christie's
point as well yes we are aware of those
sorts of issues and that's
partially why we want to bring in this
this harbour policy to give
um to make it clear and to give us some
control
over things like that that happening
um as paul said they are under a court
order but that doesn't
um deal with the storage
of material on the river bank etc
um and we do believe that that's a
danger and would want to be able to deal
with it
not that we can't deal with it now but
it will be easier if we've got a policy
um to be able to enforce
councilman golf
very much another question uh please and
it's to do with the the wrecks we've got
in the river at the moment um
if this apology apology policies agreed
would we actually be implementing
removal of these wrecks that we have
there
to actually show the public we actually
started doing something in there in the
river itself
because it's looking like an eyesore at
the moment right opposite where the
wharf is at moment you've got a few
wrecks scattered around
you know what what is the plan forward
and get rid of these wrecks or does it
now become some eco thing
they got to stay there question for that
one there and
i think nobody answered about the the 24
7 access
um i've raised it with you a few times
um stacy that um
people find it hard to get uh a response
now
i don't personally believe that because
i've actually tried hard mass myself and
got through it
now you know are these personal
vendettas if they are they need to be
nipped in the bud straight away because
it's not helpful
going forward it's not a good way to be
working so can i have
that's nothing against mister the base
that nothing at all you know because
he's been nipped in the bud because i
hear it quite a lot going around
and just some sort of clarification i'm
not trying to put them on the spot
but people were saying trying to say it
takes a long time to get response and
there's no i'm not regarded as nothing
to do with covert this is pre-covered
so can we have any i'm being straight
and open what i've been told by
residents okay
um thank you councillor um
over the last few months we've recovered
a number of wrecks
um our jurisdiction is
effectively between the two bridges um
we've recovered a number of wrecks in
the last few months
downstream is another issue which
it is on our agenda to deal with um
yes we will you'll see us recovering
more wrecks
over the course of time some of them are
historic
um but we have recovered a couple of
wrecks in the last few months
and also we if you recall brunswick
wharf
we went through a whole process of wreck
removal there
and we not only do we do remove a number
of
houseboats from that site we we
recovered and disposed of a significant
number of
arrests so that's in hand that's uh
that's ongoing wreck removal um
about the issue of of of being able to
get hold of people at the harbor
authority
um you're looking at it really um i
i'm a part-time officer here i'm
employed on on a part-time basis
by the council i have one uh
uh crane ukraine um driver who comes in
on a part-time basis one day a week
and a part-time um pilot pilot
and crew we have had discussions
about the future of the harbour and how
how we would be able to respond more to
stakeholders and in order to do that yes
you you need to you need we need to
think about um having someone who's
there on a
much more full-time basis and it's not
it's not lost on me
and it's not lost on richard we are
actively
um discussing it as part of our plans
for the future of the harbour and if you
want to have
that sort of immediate response then
you're going to have to have offices
and resources at the harbour on a much
more full-time basis but i do what i can
in the part-time role that tdc gives me
thank you we could just juggle with that
a little bit i would have thought by
sort of if paul is not working on a day
well the calls have got to go through
richard's office
if richard's got responsibility to some
extent for the harbor
he's answering the phone all the time on
his rubbish he can do with the theory
with the harbor
except for friday nights i know he's
otherwise occupied
oh richard sorry sorry yeah that that's
fine
and while paul is um and i know
kensington mcguff
uh there's been a one or two occasions
um but you know like you said i
i can get older paul even though he
works three days
and he is generally on call and does um
answer his phone but likewise i'm
accessible
um and we will be looking at the the
website pages to update them for contact
details
um there is the email address but like a
lot of these things that as you know
coaster magoff you know forward planning
um is key especially when you're coming
into the harbor or want something you
know activities if
like anything in your business if
someone rings you on a friday night they
want you on saturday sometimes it can't
happen
um but likewise yeah there's also sean
as well
who's got a wealth of experience um
and yeah that that would be updated on
the website
um and if and no one else or we're all
engineers and it will go through to the
switchboard
so someone should be able to contact
someone within the authority
thank you chair okay stacy
thank you i just wanted to come back on
councillor margot's point about the
wrecks
because that's a really valid point and
that's part of the difficulty that we've
had
um as as paul said we have cleared quite
a few wrecks
um and actually it's cost us tens of
thousands to do that
and that's another reason why we
desperately need um this morning's
policy
um because as you'll as members will see
at page 25
one of the stipulations is that all of
the boat owners have insurance
and specifically wreck removal insurance
so that the council isn't left with the
cost of clearing
the boats from the harbour because it's
really really expensive
um and we want to stop that going
forward along with stopping the
complaints that we've got
in relation to the state of the harbor
thank you stacy sean
thank you i mean richard parsley
answered what i was going to say anyway
but
but in relation and just for just for
the members so that you you have some
comfort
um if if it were an emergency situation
obviously you'd be directed from our
switchboard to the emergency standby
line
and from there you know let's say
there's a pollution event
outside of ours that would then trigger
a number of
things where richard or myself or
another senior officer would
step in to take control of the situation
so there is that cover there for
emergencies but the point was to be made
i think about the operational activity
okay councillor mcgolf
thanks sherman um straight away to mr
harbour master
i wasn't aware that you only worked
part-time uh thank you much for
clarifying that to me
uh obviously the amir all the way along
since i met you in previous council
is to give you the power you actually
need to carry your job efficiently
and to give you the sport that you need
to goes with it so you know i'm more
in favor for that totally um thank you
much for the concerns about the
wrecks and unfortunately what it costs
the taxpayers the removal of them
um but i'm very confident that the heart
master will start working to remove a
few more which is great
and i'm very pleased to see that um
informed obviously it goes through the
emergency line so
next time i get anybody complaining to
me i can then tell them directly
what i've just been told in the
committee that takes place so in office
of time as well isn't it so thank you
okay chair mr gibbs would like to speak
and councillor rossi
certainly okay um
can i cover a point on on general
directions i
i think we all know that with the
the bylaws that we have of 1896 whatever
they are
we're really fairly powerless and we've
really got to do something
and the shortest the most efficient way
is going to be get to get general
directions
because then we can actually start to
manage the harbor for the first time
properly
you are the next one
a little bit slow on this still bob
sorry um there's a couple of questions
i talked to paul about this yesterday i
think about
um the definition of a wreck which i
think is important to put in the policy
um because you will come up against so
many arguments
uh for example bob renton with his boat
saying is anchored i mean i challenge
bob to move that boat
you know um the other thing is with the
the tender for the wreck removal um does
that go out locally or is that
something who does that
um yeah thank you um uh councillor
um before this before the moorings party
goes up to cnr i'll i shall put in the
definition of a wreck
um the wrecks to date have um
in the last couple of months we've done
it we've done it in-house
um they've been small enough to uh to do
in-house
um yeah yeah yeah past february
i'll just buy in paul that's all um it's
just that if there's any
uh large effects that were going to be
removed i'd i would like to see it go
out
locally for tender you know so all the
money stays locally hopefully so
absolutely yeah i have heard on the
jungle drums that torridge deals with
its wrecks on saturday mornings i don't
know whether i'm right or not
councillor magoff
thank you mr chairman uh just a quick
question about the the dredging of the
the river are we there to do that or is
it just financially not sound and
not i see cancer christians shaking his
head
vigorously at me there so i think i
better just shut up on that one
no you asked the question yeah well i
will ask questions you know i don't shut
up anyway but
um yeah is that something we can do or
we're not allowed to do that
to for eyesight you know aesthetically
get it nice nice looking but no okay
well you you if you're talking about
dredging brunswick warf
and and and and dredging the the arizona
benefit we could do it we'd have to have
the various licenses
and that would have been including the
environment agency who are represented
at today's meeting
i believe and we'd have to get a license
from the marine management organisation
i can certainly investigate costs
counsellor but you're talking a
very very large amount of money
councillor christie yeah just coming
back
come back on the dredging idea because
uh i suspect council mcgrath has had it
the same as i have
it comes up time time again with members
of the public why don't you dredge it
well firstly of course the estuary is a
triple s i
and the hub master is quite right we
have to apply for all sorts of licenses
before you could do it and the other
problem is if you've
uh if you care to read or at least
struggle to read professor pedic's
report
which he did a few years ago now on
the whole flow within the river uh
dredging
it is pointless really because the stuff
just comes back
and it comes in from the sea uh
weirdly he pointed out that most of the
material comes in from the sea so unless
you're going to erect
barriers across the s3 to stop it coming
in uh dredging once you start dredging
you have to do it forever
and the big problem and i suspect our
harbor master would agree
that if you start dredging the pilot
would have a nightmare trying to get
boats up the river
because it would change it so often and
so quickly he would never know where the
deep channel was
um it has been dredged before the the
british trust actually paid for it to be
dredged
but that was in the 18th century they
only ever did it once
you remember that do you peter
right now we've got the
recommendation that the
report be discussed which in fairness
members have
the second part of the recommendation is
the decision taken to implement the
moorings and facility policy
and that the report proceed to cnr for
ratification
with further consultation to take place
um and well you can read the
recommendation on page 17.
um is anyone going to how do we feel
about it we've discussed it
to me if the harbour is going to go
forward you've got to get
things sorted out it's muddled for
generations
hence we are where we are
so from the chair i will propose it
well i will second that wholeheartedly
definitely
councilman golf
thank you chair obviously when the
report comes back to cnr we'd have the
financial estimates that's going to come
back to cnr so obviously i would be
happy to support this
and cancer rossi don't butt in use your
hand put your hand up
i'm happy to support that thank you
thank you
right well can i put it to a vote yeah
sorry before we do that mr puddy would
like to speak
oh sorry i can't pick up mr puddy from
my system
no you probably can't see me um just
what i wanted to ask is on page 20
i'm looking at the use of facilities and
um what is what it's saying here is that
um
people can't sleep on boats unless they
have um
holding tanks um first of all does that
apply to visiting yachts coming into the
harbour
and secondly is there any proposal along
with water and electricity to provide a
pump out facility
which will be equally as important for
the residential boats that we have in
the harbour
thank you for that john um it's
certainly an aspiration yes
could i ask that you put that
put that in writing to us as part of the
consultation that we can consider and
take forward to see in our committee
please
yes of course you
any other comments
right i think it needs a recorded vote
this one
thank you chair councillor hicks
for councillor mcgoff
four chancellor christie or
penciller james or pennsylvania
or mr gibbs or
unanimous chair unanimous thank you
now tell me if i'm wrong but i believe
that brings us to the end of the meeting
which means i can declare it closed at
15 30 which means it took exactly an
hour
now thank you for your attendance and
for those of the public who are watching
i hope you found it helpful
i declare the meeting closed